about one in six American workers more
than 26 million people have filed for
unemployment benefits in the past few
weeks earlier this year we began
following for Kansas aerospace workers
who were laid off when Boeing suspended
production of the 737 max jet they were
finding the job hunt very difficult
before the coronavirus hit now it is
all-out crisis Kris Van Cleave has his
story
it's pretty bleak right now it's just
scary time to be without a job it really
is how many cars Chris jump got laid off
as an aircraft mechanic just weeks
before coronavirus shut down much of the
US economy
it's been a long frustrating search we
first met the father of four at a job
fair in Wichita Kansas in February and
the options weren't good then I'll have
to find two jobs to make the money that
I was making in order to keep my house
if it comes down to buying food for my
kids or buying insulin for myself I'm
picking food for my kids so how are you
feeling now and when you're talking
about picking between your medicine and
food for the family
scared diabetes almost killed me two
years ago but I'm not gonna tell my kid
hey you can't have no spaghetti tonight
because dad needs insulin no that kid's
gonna get a meal until dad's laying in
the ground we talked with four laid off
aerospace workers before social
distancing was in place all were
scrambling to find work their severance
has now run out and their health
insurance will end next week all four
are still unemployed how many of you
have kids you need to support and how
many of you feel like you have the
savings to get you through until you
find the next right job you're not even
gonna happen Carol Edwards is taking
care of her daughter and four grandkids
she's been waiting three weeks for an
unemployment check and can't wait much
longer I have like $400 left my
grandkids don't understand why I cry why
were struggling
my there's very little food in the house
rent is due again next Friday
Carol worries she could lose everything
what is your hope for being able to find
another job slimmed in then right now so
I'm between a rock and a hard place with
nowhere to go I feel like I'm drowning
the sad truth is the job market in
Wichita like so many places is virtually
frozen right now we're reaching out to
the state of Kansas trying to figure out
why Carol's unemployment checks have
been so delayed Anthony yeah
heartbreaking for those families Kris
and their skilled workers do we just
can't find work